SAM DUTTON: We're live.
Great.
Well, welcome everyone to
the WebRTC hangout.
So we're looking forward
to some really
good questions today.
We've already had some good
stuff on Moderator.
We're going to talk a bit about
the basics of WebRTC.
You know, what it is, what it
can do for you, and how you
can use it now-- how you
can get started.
And so first I'd like
to introduce you
to the people here.
Yeah.
My name is Sam Dutton.
I'm a developer advocate
for Chrome--
for Google, based in London--
and yeah-- just learning
about WebRTC.
It's a fantastic technology.
So I've been talking to these
guys from the team.
So over to Mountain View.
If you could introduce
yourselves, starting with Ray.
PUNYABRATA RAY: Hi my name's
Punyabrata Ray , and I'm a
technical solutions engineer
on the WebRTC Chrome team.
And--
pass it over to Ronghua.
RONGHUA WU: Hey, this
is Ronghua Wu.
I'm also a software engineer
in WebRTC Chrome team.
ERIC BIDELMAN: And hi,
I'm Eric Bidelman.
I work on our Chrome developer
relations team.
I specialize in HTML5--
kind of help developers
learn all the cool
new stuff in HTML5--
of course, there's
plenty of that--
and also contribute a lot to
html5rocks.com, which is our--
one of our developer's sites
geared toward HTML5
development.
SAM DUTTON: A great site.
And I'll just put
a URL for that.
Eric, while you're there, I was
just wondering if we could
look at the demo that you
produced earlier with Pete, to
show off some of the features
of WebRTC, and just maybe
could talk us through
that a little bit.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So for those
that aren't familiar with,
sort of, what WebRTC is, we--
Pete and I shot an
entertaining--
to say the least--
screen shot yesterday for you
guys just to sort of show off
what WebRTC is in a fun kind
of interesting way.
So I think he's working on
dialing it up right now.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah,
I can see it.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Cool.
PUNYABRATA RAY: Right.
And just in case people
are not aware--
MALE SPEAKER: Hey, Eric.
What's up?
ERIC BIDELMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
MALE SPEAKER: Hey.
This WebRTC stuff?
It seems pretty cool, right?
ERIC BIDELMAN: Yeah, it is.
I'm kind of thirsty down here.
Can you help me out?
MALE SPEAKER: You know,
I think I can.
I'll be right there.
[LAUGHTER]
SAM DUTTON: Magic--
the magic of WebRTC.
That's great.
Thank you very much,
Pete and Eric.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So in the
directions out there-- there's
a demo that we'll talk a little
bit about maybe in a
bit, but apprtc.appspot.com is a
sample app that you can test
out that is exactly what we
just showed you, which is
establishing a connection
with someone else.
You saw Pete and I do a
real-time video chat in the
Googleplex.
So obviously, you know,
Googleplex has some
interesting things like slides,
so we decided to ham
it up a bit, if you will.
Pete got me a water in
an interesting way.
But that just goes to show
you, it's all in
the browser, right?
We were just hitting a URL
without any plug-ins or
anything-- doing real-time live
video chat and audio.
Very cool stuff.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, that's
really great.
And it looks good and
the quality of
the video is fantastic.
So I guess I wanted to
start, if I could, by
asking Ray and Ronghua.
That's kind of a big question
about-- you know, what are we
doing with WebRTC?
What are the big aims
for WebRTC here?
PUNYABRATA RAY: So I'll
start that out.
Essentially, one of the main
components to push Chrome as a
platform is real-time
communications.
And to be able to do that
natively in the browser and
not just Chrome-- any
browsers out there--
so bringing this functionality,
transcending
operating systems, and being
able to set up a call between
two browsers natively.
And developers essentially don't
have to worry about the
nitty-gritty and the underlying
signaling
processing blocks or how to
traverse firewalls and such.
You can just write your own
web page and make a call.
SAM DUTTON: That's brilliant.
OK.
So at the moment, we're doing
stuff with real-time
conferencing with the kind of
video applications that we
just saw a moment ago.
Have you got any--
Ronghua, have you got any other
ideas for the kind of
apps that we might be seeing in
the future that use WebRTC.
RONGHUA WU: There's
a lot of potential
apps to help you there.
One of them may be, like
for customer service.
For example, if you go to a
website, you just click on
that, you can read your customer
[? percentage. ?]
Another basic one's like,
peer-to-peer calls.
You can set up a website that
with a button, you can talk to
someone else without any
plug-in involved.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, fantastic.
RONGHUA WU: You can also do
some, like, screen sharing or
streaming your local files
using these technologies.
ERIC BIDELMAN: What we're
starting to see, too, is like
the ability for HTML5 APIs
like web sockets, for
instance, support sending binary
data in these different
file formats.
And so you can combine that in
really interesting ways now
with other stuff in
the platform.
So what I did with that is kind
of compelling to me is to
build a robot that sort
of drives itself.
You know, I don't know-- put a
laptop on some kind of car or
something and it does--
SAM DUTTON: Cool, yeah.
ERIC BIDELMAN: --some action as
it drives around using the
input it gets from the video
and sort of does--
in real-time using a web
worker or something--
the video processing on it.
So maybe still futuristic,
but definitely doable,
prototypable.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, I can imagine
a lot of really good
education applications
with this, as well.
You know, being able
to communicate--
teachers and students
communicating remotely and
taking advantage of that.
And even--
like Rana's suggesting--
you know, just working
with customers--
talking customers through
technical support and really
any kind of stuff.
Yeah, it's really exciting.
The possibilities are there.
I just wanted to quickly go--
just to show another little
demo just to kick off.
One of the really important
components of what people are
doing with WebRTC is the
get-user media API.
This is a way of getting
streaming media from your
computer and then working
with the data.
Here's a really simple
example.
I'll just try and pop this
up on-screen and
share it with you.
If we can do a little screen
share here, I'll see if I can
get this on the hangout.
So I'm sharing a window now
which we can move to.
So can you see me?
Does it look a bit weird?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ERIC BIDELMAN: You look great.
SAM DUTTON: As you can see,
we're getting in real-time, a
creepy, hairy ball.
So we're getting video data
directly from the camera on my
machine here and doing
processing
of the data in real-time.
And then displaying that
rendering content immediately.
And as you can see, it's a
kind of fun application.
But you can imagine, there's
a lot of potential useful
implementations that you can get
with this kind of stuff.
So real-time processing of
video using the data from
get-user media.
ERIC BIDELMAN: That's using
WebGEO, right Sam?
Is that right?
Like, WebGEO filter
effects for that?
SAM DUTTON: Yeah,
that's right.
And I don't know if
you can see this.
Does this work for you?
ERIC BIDELMAN: Yeah,
we can see it.
SAM DUTTON: Cool.
And there, you can see, what
we're outputing to is a canvas
element there.
So right there we're seeing
the output rendered on a
canvas element.
I'll put up a link to that so
anyone can go to that right
now from the hangout.
There we go.
OK.
And there we go.
I'll turn off screen sharing now
so you don't have to see
this psychedelic image of me.
Why don't we take a question
from the Moderator stuff that
we've had today.
So, yes, starting up right from
the most popular question
we've had so far on Moderator.
The question is--
I'll just put the link so that
people can go to this page if
they want to have a look and
want to add questions.
There we go.
So the first question here is,
can you share a timeline for
recording APIs to become
available.
And they have a link for
the Google group's
question about that.
So yeah, I was wondering, Ray
and Ronghua , could you
enlighten us about this?
What's the estimate for
this at this stage?
Is this something that we
can see on the road map?
PUNYABRATA RAY: Yeah,
definitely.
I think this is definitely
on our road map.
From what I heard, we were
shooting for most probably
second quarter.
Perhaps it might sneak into
the third quarter.
We're just totally focused right
now on just making sure
that everything works in a
peer-to-peer call, and then
move to the next feature sets of
being able to record and do
other things.
So hopefully Q2, if not Q3 of
this year, we should have
these recording APIs
up and running.
SAM DUTTON: That's
great to hear.
It seems like it's well-defined
and ready to go.
That's great news.
Just taking another question
from Moderator.
They're asking about
experimental servers.
Could you run an experimental
server?
Thus it would be easier for
people to try the technology?
It would be temporary and
unguaranteed, obviously.
And yeah, I believe we have
that in place, yeah?
Is that correct?
RONGHUA WU: Yeah.
In order to run the experiment,
essentially, you
need two servers.
One is the server for the
net [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
We have scanned at google.com.
That is already there.
You can configure up your
connection to use that.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
you will need a signaling
server.
So we do have an open source--
very simple one- signaling
server sample in our website.
You can see that and
view it yourself.
PUNYABRATA RAY: It's a peer
connection server.
RONGHUA WU: That's a
very simple one.
You can use that to test
the [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
[? net-- ?]
the server behind
the app RTC--
the demo we just saw.
That one, we plan to open
source it very soon.
SAM DUTTON: That's
great to hear.
One thing I failed to
mention so far--
a really great source of
information about WebRTC is
the WebRTC site itself.
I'll just add a link to that.
That's WebRTC.org.
I'm just putting that up now.
So there's a lot of great
information there--
documentation, and some demos,
and links to further
information, and blog posts,
and a lot of stuff that you
can listen out to that gives
updates pretty regular.
There's a really active
community around WebRTC.
And we're seeing a lot of new
information coming through
daily, so have a look at that.
And it's a great place
to get started.
Just looking through the other
questions on Moderator here--
So I guess this harks back
to the last question.
What server implementations are
now available to build a
video chat service
using WebRTC?
So I believe that one thing
that's on the way is some kind
of open source server.
Is that correct?
Is that something we're
going to see?
RONGHUA WU: Yeah,
that's correct.
That's the server I mentioned
at behind the
apprtc.appspot.com, that
demo app we just saw.
The signaling server behind
that, we plan to
open source it soon.
SAM DUTTON: That's really
good to hear.
I couldn't resist-- sorry--
I'm going to show another
one of these--
PUNYABRATA RAY: Do you know
if there's any other ones
available that people
have built?
Or is it just too
soon, maybe, to
RONGHUA WU: Yeah,
it's too soon.
But we do have a very simple
one-- that's what I
mentioned--
this peer connection server
in the [? code name. ?]
So we have it on our website--
open source.
ERIC BIDELMAN: That's in the
project page for WebRTC?
Google the project page, yeah.
So Sam, you want to throw that
one up, too, which is I think
is probably going to be
off the WebRTC.org.
PUNYABRATA RAY: Right.
That's one thing that I think
people as, at least, newcomers
to this project definitely
need to understand-- that
there's obviously the client
side things that we're
providing that will take care
of capturing your microphone
samples and video frames from
your camera, encoding that,
sending it out.
And then there is a server
component that--
you might have two clients who
can't see each other because
they're sitting behind
firewalls and such.
So there's this server component
also that we are
providing, but people also need
to understand that as, if
they want to scale this out,
they do need to perhaps spend
a little bit more time thinking
about how they would
want to handle 1,000 calls
and things like that.
But this is a good
start, I think.
We have sample applications--
both, obviously on the client
side and the server side.
And we're going to open up a
real server that we're using.
So hopefully, these will be good
building steps for people
to start building their
applications soon.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, sure.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Sam, I wonder if
it makes sense at this time
to bring up that slide deck and
show that diagram of sort
of the architecture?
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
Let me just get that.
Hold on a moment.
And get that stuff.
ERIC BIDELMAN: How much stuff
is actually going into the
project, right?
There's sort of the browser
implementation, right, which
is all open source as I
understand it, right?
PUNYABRATA RAY: Right.
ERIC BIDELMAN: The browser's
implementation that the
browser's implementing--
but there's also all the
JavaScript APIs, which is the
part where the web developers
come in and play with the
portion of the WebRTC that you
can actually use from an app.
And so, Sam I think, is trying
to bring up this really nice,
sort of diagram showing
all this.
And what I usually
show people is--
as soon as he gets it up--
there's a lot under the hood.
There's a ton of stuff going
on-- and this is what you
spoke to earlier--
is that there's a lot of
fine-tuning going on.
There's a lot of implementation
details.
And so over time, we're going
to start to work on other
stuff, as well, like recording,
for instance.
SAM DUTTON: While I'm getting
this up on-screen, I was
wondering--
one thing that I would love
to hear is you WebRTC guys
talking through the process of
that really basic demo we saw
right at the start there.
You know, what's going on?
Could you talk us through the
process of actually making the
connection and getting
the video from A to
B and B to A again.
PUNYABRATA RAY: Sure.
I don't know--
should we start at the lowest
level first, or should we
start at the highest level,
working down?
RONGHUA WU: Maybe you can start
with, open up a camera
and [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
PUNYABRATA RAY: Right.
OK.
So there's two parts.
From the web developer's
perspective, which is not what
I'm going to start with.
You know, they're working with
JavaScript APIs and they're
going to set up a call.
But going down to the very low
level, we have what we call
the voice and video engines
aspect of the WebRTC.
And these are the engines--
starting from one end, where
we start grabbing microphone
samples and the video frames
from the camera, encode them,
and packetize them and send
them out into the network.
And on the reverse end,
when we receive
packets from the network--
decode them, and then display
and render the decoded video
frames, and play out the sound
samples to your speakers.
That's in a nutshell what
the media engines do.
There's different components.
For example, there's an acoustic
echo cancellation
block and a noise suppression
block on the voice engine side
to provide you really
good quality.
This is not just about
making video calls.
This is about providing really,
really good voice and
video quality.
And then, in addition to that,
there's the codecs-- the audio
and video codecs--
that encode your raw microphone
samples and raw
video frames so that they're
sent out in a reasonable bit
rate out to the network.
And then setting a bit in
conjunction with the video and
audio codecs are bandwidth
estimation, and traffic
shaping, and how to adjust
your bit rates based on
network conditions.
So that's all on the
media layer side.
And then on top of that, we want
to encapsulate this so
that web developers don't need
to worry about this.
And it will work on any
platforms. Then on top of
that, sits some of how this
talks to the browsers and on
top of that, the JavaScript
layers.
And maybe, Ronghua you can speak
a little about that--
about the peer connection
APIs.
RONGHUA WU: Yeah, I guess
you covered it well.
Another thing is, if you have
two browsers behind the
firewall, we need to find
out a way for them to
talk to each other.
That is when your net
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
.
Kick in So there is some
technique inside libjingle.
So basically, you need to talk
to a server with a public IP.
We call it a [? scan ?]
server.
You talk to that server, then
that server will figure out
which part is reachable
to you.
And then in that phase
we call it candidates
So when you collect all the
candidates , you exchange the
candidates with the
remote peer.
That remote peer knows
how to reach you.
After that we can send the media
stream we produced by
the media engine.
So that's how a call--
we set up.
PUNYABRATA RAY: And so from the
web developer perspective,
you would just call these peer
connection APIs, which you
might see the layer that Ronghua
just spoke about.
And then once the media's
established, that media is
passed to the media engine
layer underneath WebRTC.
SAM DUTTON: That's it.
Right.
I've just posted--
ERIC BIDELMAN: It is complex.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, it's
pretty complex.
But I've just posted a link
if you can see that the
apprtc.appspot.com link there.
That's to the really
simple demo.
So if you want to take a look
at the code there, that's a
really good place
to get started.
I've also put up a link you
can see above that to
demo.appspot.com To the
architecture diagram that Eric
was talking about.
I think if I can get that
up on-screen now--
I'll try and do a screen
share of that one.
OK.
So I'm showing that stuff now.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Can you zoom
in on the slides?
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
Let's try and improve
that a bit.
How's that?
That's pretty good, yeah?
ERIC BIDELMAN: A little
bit more, maybe.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's great.
SAM DUTTON: How we doing?
I could even go a little
bit further, maybe.
Maybe that was one step
over the line.
Ray and Ronghua , could you--
just to repeat everything
you've just told me--
can you talk us through this--
what looks in some ways a
rather complex diagram?
It would be great to hear from
you, from kind of top to
bottom, what's going
on in this diagram.
PUNYABRATA RAY: Sure,
absolutely.
I'll start, Ronghua.
So the one thing when someone
looks at this diagram is--
definitely look at the different
colors and what as a
web developer, as opposed to a
browser implementer, what they
really need to worry about.
So essentially, I'm assuming
most of the people who look at
this hangout will be
web developers.
And what they first need to
think about is, essentially,
the top level-- where you have
yellow arrows in this diagram.
Your web application and what
they're going to essentially
design-- a website
or a web app.
And that will essentially then
talk to these web APIs, which
are the peer connection APIs
that are currently being
discussed and ratified
in the W3W.
RONGHUA WU: W3C.
PUNYABRATA RAY: W3C, sorry--
World Wide Consortium.
And those are the peer
connection APIs.
The layer that Ronghua earlier
talked about, where these will
essentially set up the call and
once the call is set up,
pass the media blocks into
the media engines.
So then as you move down--
that purple arrow going into
the WebRTC C API peer
connection--
this section is how the
different browser vendors have
to worry about, from Chrome
to Mozilla, to Opera.
This will somewhat be different
between the
different--
how they choose to implement
the peer connection APIs
within their browser.
And correct me if I'm
wrong, Ronghua. .
So the web developers
don't really have
to worry about that.
Again, we're now getting to the
layer which-- this will be
encapsulated within the
browsers itself.
And then the layers
beneath that are--
what I mentioned about the
physical media engines, where
we handle the actual media
processing of the voice and
video packets--
the different codecs used to
encode and decode, the traffic
shaping, the acoustic echo
cancellation blocks.
So those are the lower
level purple blocks.
And Ronghua , I'm not sure--
the session management
abstract signaling layer.
I don't know how that quite fits
in, or if we need to go
into that in this part, or
that's encapsulated by the
peer connection.
RONGHUA WU: Yeah, in this
diagram, this is the
signaling, and session is part
of this WebRTC C API.
So the discussion going on
that might be moved up a
little bit so that the
application developers have
the flexability to choose
whatever signaling protocol
they want to use in
their application.
Yeah.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So I'm glad
Sam is showing this.
Because it's illustrative of
what the platform is doing
these days, right?
There's a lot of guts to it.
There's a lot of core
implementations that the
browser is taking care for you
as you look at this diagram.
Everything below that--
in that lighter gray box--
everything below those arrows
is totally a black box.
You don't have to
worry about it.
PUNYABRATA RAY: That's
a good point.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Another thing
is the JavaScript APIs that
you built on top of.
But they're--
just keep in mind-- it's
important to know that there's
a lot of stuff built into these
different HTML5 APIs now.
Another example is
WebGL, right?
You can access the GPU and the
graphics card with a couple
lines of JavaScript.
It's ridiculous.
It's ridiculously cool
is what it is.
So kudos to Google and the
engineers at Google for
implementing all this crazy,
awesome stuff for us.
SAM DUTTON: That's
good to hear.
Look, I can't resist--
sorry--
just to break from the
technicalities for a moment.
I just wanted to go to another
demo of get user media that I
really like.
If I can just share that.
In a few seconds, I'll
just move the video.
And I just wanted to show this
because, again, we're doing
stuff with live video data.
I don't know if anyone remembers
the exploding video
experiment that Sean
Christman did.
So here you can see, me
on the video there.
I'll try and increase
the size a bit.
And you can see that
if I click on
the picture, it explodes.
And what's cool is that you
could see that all those
individual pieces are still
rendering the video.
If you can see, the little
squares are still showing
live, the stuff as
I move around.
That makes it a little
clearer.
So I just love that
there is so much
potential for this stuff--
some useful stuff, and obviously
some fun stuff like
that, as well.
Just going back to the Moderator
questions, another
one we've heard a lot of is
asking if the API is going to
become available on
mobile devices.
And particularly, what obstacles
do we need to
overcome before we can
get to that point?
So could I turn over to
Ray and Ronghua again?
PUNYABRATA RAY: Yeah.
No, definitely, I think that's
also one of our high
priorities in the future.
Once we know that this is
stabilized on the desktop
platforms, we would love to
move this to the mobile
devices, both Android and iOS.
Unfortunately, I don't know what
our exact timelines are.
But I know that this is
something we would be very,
very focused on in moving.
So the obstacles essentially
right now is time.
There are so many engineers and
we just need to focus on
getting this working perfectly
on a certain platform--
the desktop platforms--
and then move ahead to
the mobile platforms.
SAM DUTTON: That's
great to hear.
PUNYABRATA RAY: Oh, Sam?
I think we lost your audio.
SAM DUTTON: Oh, sorry.
Is that better?
Yes.
I think I'm back.
OK, good.
I have a mic.
Just moving down the
questions, I
have another one here.
Someone is asking if we could
give more details about
multi-peer issues.
Could you explain a little about
that, and tell us what
the situation is?
PUNYABRATA RAY: Sure.
Let me actually just understand
the question a bit.
Could you give more details
about multi-peer issues.
So I'm going to interpret this
question as the user wants to
know essentially how to set up
like, a video conference
apparently using--
So what we allow today is the
ability to make peer-to-peer
calls and the media is
essentially relayed through
different servers.
I don't know if it is possible
today, but it should be
possible in the future to
be able to render--
if you have multiple video
streams coming in--
to render the multiple images.
That's true.
Right, Ronghua?
RONGHUA WU: Yeah, that
sounds right.
I'm reading this question.
I'm thinking maybe he was
asking how to maybe have
multiple peer connections
in one place.
PUNYABRATA RAY: Browser?
RONGHUA WU: Because this is
one issue I know of--
not issue-- but, not
implemented yet.
We only support one peer
connection in one
page at this moment.
PUNYABRATA RAY: But that's
definitely something that's
going to be changed
and we're going to
support that in the future.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Is this something
that the current
specification talks about at
all, or is it just talking
about one-to-one and
peer-to-peer?
PUNYABRATA RAY: That's
a good question.
I don't know.
[LAUGHTER]
SAM DUTTON: OK.
So another question we had
earlier on on Moderator from
Clive Bolton, asking if the
standard behind the API is
designed more for asynchronous
or synchronous communication.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
in either case is a concept of
time bounding, making latency
predictable.
PUNYABRATA RAY: This question,
given that there are so many
layers in WebRTC--
there's the media layer,
and the voice and
video engine packets.
The way it's been designed, the
voice and video streams
take different routes through
the networks, and are
subjected to different
latencies and paths.
And our engines have been
designed to overcome that.
They will work irrespective
of that.
However, I'm not sure exactly
which aspect of WebRTC this
question is designed to.
If he's actually talking about
the media layer or if he's
talking about the
JavaScript APIs.
So I'm not sure exactly
how to answer that.
I don't know what your take
on that is, Ronghua.
RONGHUA WU: I don't have a good
answer for that, either.
PUNYABRATA RAY: Right.
SAM DUTTON: One thing I was
going to say that--
I'll put up the link
in a moment.
But if people have comments on
the answers that we've had to
questions, if they can add
comments to the Google page,
that would be great.
And I'll put up a link
to that in a moment.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Just to speak
to that question-- if he is
talking about the JavaScript
application APIs--
it is an asynchronous API.
You're sort of adding
messages, you're
doing message passing.
And that's good because like a
lot of offline APIs, Indexed
DB, the file system APIs, some
of these other APIs that are
coming online, they're always
synchronous because there's a
lot of stuff going on when
you're making these calls.
And the last thing you want to
do is sort of freeze up your
JavaScript main UI thread.
So I think in the future, you're
going to see a ton of
asynchronous JavaScript APIs.
It's sort of the way
things are going.
Unfortunately, JavaScript's a
single threaded environment,
so you have to do that in order
to make applications
that people don't tear their
hair out for because it's so
slow and obnoxious.
SAM DUTTON: Sure.
Yeah.
A question from a
guy called Pete.
He's in Mountain View.
I think that that's
in California.
He's asking what codec is
Google's implementation of
WebRTC encoding the
video stream with.
And what do the other browser
vendors think?
He says that he reckons Opera's
working on this, as well.
What's the story?
Are we working with VP8, and
what's the future there?
PUNYABRATA RAY: Yes, we are
using VP8, which was part of a
company called On2 that Google
acquired a few years back.
And Google has open sourced
this video codec.
It's completely out there.
It's part of the WebM Project.
And given that the whole
objective of WebRTC is to be
open, we decided to go with VP8
and not have any loyalty
encumbered codecs to use with
an open source project.
So we are using VP8 today
as a video codec.
As far as what the other
browsers vendors think, I
can't really comment on that.
But again, given the fact that
VP8 is open source, I think
they're pretty much on board.
But again, that's just
my personal--
I'm sure the big question is
interoperability and what's
going to happen with H264.
That's something that comes up a
lot in our discussion lists.
And it's just that that's
big on our minds, too.
But again, we want to stay
with an open source
royalty-free codec so that
anyone can use this and not
have to worry about royalties.
ERIC BIDELMAN: This kind of
segues nicely into a question
I'm seeing later on from Neo
in New York City-- is about
sort of other browser
vendors--
Firefox--
i.e., Safari-- working on WebRTC
and implementing it in
their browsers.
Could we talk a little bit about
sort of what's going on
with the community?
PUNYABRATA RAY: Sure.
And Ronghua, cut me in or
because you might know more.
RONGHUA WU: No, you have
more information.
PUNYABRATA RAY: So I
know that we are--
so the peer connection
APIs, for example.
This is being ratified in
the standard at Mozilla.
It's part of that.
So this is just not solely
a Google initiative.
We start this, but we would like
other browser vendors to
obviously, use WebRTC.
So we're working with Mozilla,
and we're also
working with Opera.
IE and Safari right now--
I don't know what the
engagement level is,
especially with IE
at this point.
So essentially I don't know,
and I can't make
much comments on it.
Same thing with Apple, Safari.
I believe they're
also actually--
people from Apple-- are
part of the standards.
I don't know if they're going to
go with WebRTC and Safari.
But--
think--
I believe they're working
on the standards, also.
So essentially, to wrap that
up, Mozilla and Opera are
definitely currently on board.
Apple, I believe is working
on the standards and I'm
not sure about IE.
SAM DUTTON: Cool.
While we're on the subject of
browsers, a question a lot of
people ask me pretty regularly
is, when might we see this in
Chrome's stable?
Do we have any sense of when
that might happen?
PUNYABRATA RAY: Yeah.
No, that's a really
good question.
So right now it sits
behind a flag.
There's essentially two main
things before we can
completely open this up, and
it's not behind a flag.
One is the fact that the peer
connection APIs are still
somewhat in a state of flux.
It's still being ratified.
So once that is in a state,
maybe in the next few months--
my guess-- but I might
be completely wrong.
So the next few-- so I think
we're currently on any team
that's been open.
Maybe by M20, M21, they should
be not sitting behind a flag.
That's just my guess.
And the second aspect of
this is, also we need
people to try it out.
If there's any major issues out
there, we would like to
fix those before opening
this up by default .
ERIC BIDELMAN: And this
is my plea to you
developers out there.
The reason a lot of these APIs
exist behind about [? dot ?]
flags or behind a flag
in general is for
you to try them out.
They're still being actively
worked on.
And so this is my pitch to
install Chrome Canary, right?
This is our nightly
build of Chrome.
You saw the Dev channel
We actually rely on you guys
very heavily to submit bugs,
to tell us what's wrong with
these APIs, to test them in
the field, so to speak, even
if it's just a prototype.
It's really useful
information.
And of course, you can
always file bugs.
Chrome is an open source
project and we very
much look at those.
I look at Issue-Tracker
every day of my life.
SAM DUTTON: That's
good to hear.
I know the feeling.
We had another question here.
Let's just look down at the
list of stuff here.
Someone asking about
web socket API to
transfer audio and video.
From what I believe, this has
been possible in Chrome.
I think since Chrome 16.
And on the service side, there
are some libraries that
support that.
So there are going to be, I
believe, some demos at some
stage about this.
So maybe, Eric, can you
enlighten us on this?
ERIC BIDELMAN: I can.
So this is something I've
actually been interested in
for a long time, is
to be able to--
there's not really a good
solution for streaming audio.
So I wanted to see if it was
possible, just as a prototype,
to build something that used
the web socket API.
So web sockets now support
sending binary data.
You can send a file or a blog,
which is exactly what you need
for low latency transfer of sort
of an audio-type file.
So using a web socket-- a binary
web socket-- with the
web audio API that's
in Chrome--
what that allows you to do is
basically send small chunks of
an audio file across
a web socket.
It's sort of a poor man's
streaming, as I
like to call it.
And then on the other side--
on the receiver side-- you can
use the web audio API to
schedule precisely when each
chunk should play.
So as the receiver starts to get
these chunks, you start to
append them on, and schedule
them at precise times when
they were supposed to play
in the initial song.
And so it pretty much just
sounds like the song is
playing straight through.
So it's very much
[? a perfect ?] concept, and I
plan to write an article
on it for html5rocks.
So stay tuned for that.
But combining web socket API
with the web audio API, you
can definitely do audio
and video streaming.
There's also another API that's
in Chrome and being
speced out.
It's called the MediaSource
API.
And essentially, what that
allows you to do is sort of
something similar-- use a video
tag or an audio tag and
sort of use XMLHttpRequest to
pull down chunks of audio or
video, and then append
those to a video tag.
So that's also kind of a poor
man's streaming, if you will.
But it does do the job,
and it allows you to--
I think what the question is
sort of getting at is to do
some [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
streaming--
audio and video.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, I've seen some
great demos of that stuff
and lots of possibilities.
It kind of--
I don't know if that's the
word-- but it kind of
[? fake ?] almost
[? seductive ?] streaming
model for that giving different
media depending on
the situation.
ERIC BIDELMAN: There's a couple
APIs that play now that
allow you to do similar things,
but different use
cases, right?
There's WebRTC for certain use
cases and direct peer-to-peer
connections.
Web sockets do similar
things to that, but
different use cases.
And then there's these
other APIs that are
sort of at play, too.
So it's kind of choose your own
battle, and use the right
technology or API for the job
that you're trying to do.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
We've got another question
coming from California, which
is interesting to
me, actually.
So we have a stack of new APIs,
and what this guy's
wondering is, are these going to
be useful for other stuff?
Is there some other stuff that
we can do with all this, other
than video?
So I suspect there is.
So if we could get some ideas
about that, that'd be great.
I'm going to disappear
because--
I'm going to be five seconds--
I need to get my power cable.
PUNYABRATA RAY: Yeah.
So this started out as a
project of real-time
communication--
voice and video chatting
between two browsers.
But I'm sure there's other
applications, like streaming.
And I'm not sure exactly
if anyone--
I don't know.
You might know if anyone
in our engineering is
specifically working on
streaming audio and video,
also in addition.
But the tricky part about
two-way communication is there
can be no delay.
With streaming, you can perhaps
wait a bit, let it
buffer up, and then let it go.
But it's a little trickier
when you want to have a
two-way call, but you can't
have any delay.
Because if not, people will be
stepping over each other.
RONGHUA WU: If you look at the
specs of the stream API, they
also mention that you can use
the camera as the source.
You can also use a local
file as a source.
So with that, you might be
able to do like a screen
sharing presentation--
those kind of stuff,
besides the video.
PUNYABRATA RAY: And even
to localized it.
For example, allowing the fact
we can capture video frames
from a person's laptop.
There could be so many other
applications as, perhaps,
camera resolution's increase,
you could do some face
recognition, you could do
some eyeball tracking.
All these other cool, neat
effects that you could add to
your applications.
SAM DUTTON: That would be
great-- that stuff.
Stuff that in the past has
been really expensive and
really not widely accessible.
So here's a question that I knew
we would get, again from
California.
Someone asking if Google
hangouts--
what we're doing now-- is
going to use WebRTC.
Is that happen going to happen
in the next six months?
They're saying, I don't want
to use a plug-in anymore.
WebRTC will be awesome!
PUNYABRATA RAY: Yeah.
That's the whole purpose
of this project.
People open up their browsers
and make a voice and video
call without having to download
an extra plug-in.
With respect to internally
what hangouts is doing, I
actually don't know.
We're completely separate
projects.
I'm sure at some point,
there will be overlap.
But at this point, I don't know
what the plan of hangouts
is and what I don't
know if you--
I'm sure there's people
already talking
about that at Google.
You know, one day,
hopefully, we can
move to a native client.
SAM DUTTON: So these
are separate
projects at the moment.
Is that right?
PUNYABRATA RAY: Correct.
SAM DUTTON: OK.
So more questions
from Moderator.
First, I would really
like to show us
another slightly foolish--
well, I shouldn't
say foolish--
entertaining.
Hang on.
If I can get another
get user media.
Hold on a minute.
Let's have a look.
There's something nice here.
OK.
So I'll just screen
share this again.
And so here we have a kind of
Photo Booth-like application.
Can you guys see that over
in Mountain View?
PUNYABRATA RAY: Yes.
SAM DUTTON: So if I click
this to begin--
PUNYABRATA RAY: Oh, cool.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, I
just love that.
It's a really fun little app.
And just beautifully
implemented.
Again, doing lovely stuff
to get content
from your own camera.
So there's some really
imaginative
material coming out.
Just to go down the questions.
One of the things I have heard
a lot is people asking about
security with Luke
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
I think you pronounce--
and he's saying, what about
the security and the flux
encryption.
Could we have a comment
on that.
PUNYABRATA RAY: I heard
the first part--
what about security.
What was the second part?
ERIC BIDELMAN: Flux
encryption?
PUNYABRATA RAY: I actually
don't know what flux
encryption is.
But the one thing that--
SAM DUTTON: I just like
to spring impossible
questions on you.
[LAUGHTER]
PUNYABRATA RAY: I would
Google it right now.
[LAUGHTER]
PUNYABRATA RAY: But one thing
about the voice and video
streams by default today, I
believe we're using secure RTP
protocols, which has been
enabled by default.
So that's in terms of security
of the RTP stream.
So that is encrypted today.
ERIC BIDELMAN: One thing that's
not there today-- and
I'm actually not sure if even a
specification says anything
about this.
But being able to access the
camera, sort of just by making
a JavaScript call, right.
Currently there's no sort of
permission dialog that comes
down that says to the user, do
you want to give this app
access to your camera
or deny that access.
And of course, that happens
with a lot of
the APIs now, right?
There's some kind of
permission level.
There's sort of on the drive-by
web-- that the user
has to buy into to allow an
application to use one of
these APIs.
So that's not there today.
I don't know if that's being
worked out, but I'm almost
certain the spec doesn't
really mention that.
Possibly in the future
that could come--
where the user has to
manually sort of--
RONGHUA WU: Actually, I believe
there's a team working
on that for Chrome.
It's called Camera UI.
Basically, allow you to grant
the access to the camera.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Oh that's cool.
Right now, it's worth mentioning
that if you have, I
guess, multiple cameras attached
to a laptop or you're
set up, then it picks
the first--
RONGHUA WU: It picks
a default one.
ERIC BIDELMAN: OK.
RONGHUA WU: But I know there's
a team work on that, but I
don't know the detail--
when, or--
ERIC BIDELMAN: Yeah.
We'll look forward
to that sometime.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
I think-- am I right in saying
that-- using the input
element, we have an
implementation on Chrome for
Android now.
So that's really cool to be
able to use a camera.
Is that correct, Eric?
ERIC BIDELMAN: That's true.
I believe Android Honeycomb,
and then now Chrome for
Android, has the ability to use
a file input, essentially.
And you can specify a certain
accept-type attribute on that
to say you want access the
camera or record a video.
It's essentially just uploading
or taking a snapshot
in time and being able to upload
that to the server.
Whatever you want
to do with it.
Where this is different-- where
WebRTC is different,
where get-user media is
different-- is that you can
capture in real-time
and then do
real-time effects on something.
So that's cool.
Hopefully, one day, Chrome for
Android could have this
ability as well-- to do
the get-user media.
But we talked a little bit
about that earlier.
SAM DUTTON: OK, cool.
We mentioned earlier some
progress with web sockets,
Another question from
Jeff in Toronto.
Video conferencing is cool and
all, but what's the status of
the data stream API?
Web sockets would be awesome.
Do we have a comment
about that?
Or do you think we've
covered that in the
earlier web socket stuff?
RONGHUA WU: As I know, the data
stream maybe hasn't been
well-defined by the spec yet.
So before that probably.
That's what I know
from the spec.
SAM DUTTON: OK.
So we'll see.
OK.
Moving down the list here.
Yeah.
There's another question from
Luke [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
asking when the server code
from apprtc.appspot.com is
going to be released.
We did mention that the code's
going to be open source.
And that's kind of
imminent, yeah.
PUNYABRATA RAY: Yes.
SAM DUTTON: Cool.
Quickly, moving on.
We've got about five
minutes left.
So we had another question from
Clive Bolton in Seattle.
He's asking, if WebRTC nudging
the browser to incubate
server-ready JavaScript
engines.
Is this something that's part of
the WebRTC work at Google,
or is this kind of really
something different?
PUNYABRATA RAY: You know,
WebRTC is firewall
traversable for media.
And that normally requires
some sort of known
server on a public IP.
So not knowing much about
node.js, I think that would be
very challenging.
But again, I'm not an expert.
Yeah, so I don't think we
would be nudging anyone.
Again, the server
implementation, it's--
if you look at our peer
connection server example,
it's at a high level.
It should be totally
up to the user.
It's not like there has to
be one way to do this.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
Yeah, sure.
Sure.
OK, quickly moving down the
questions here, something that
occurred to me, actually.
How do you stop the stream
without killing the tab?
I can imagine moving from a page
where you're getting a
video input and then doing some
browsing, and of course,
the video's still on.
What's the story with that?
PUNYABRATA RAY: I'm
not exactly--
I think you should still be
able to remember the video
tab, but I haven't--
SAM DUTTON: I mean, I guess this
is something we could do
with get-user media.
It's in a sense, it's
the way you use it.
It's not essentially
part of WebRTC.
It's how you implement the use
of get-user media and working
with the page visibility--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SAM DUTTON: As we speak.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Did
you do your part?
I've experienced
the same thing.
I think you can call
stop on the stream.
I don't know if it actually does
anything in Chrome today,
but it's probably just a bug to
be honest. I kill my tabs.
You should file it
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
SAM DUTTON: Cool.
I will.
Yeah, we that's my problem.
It was my fault.
I should have shut up.
Which syncs nicely into the next
question, again from this
guy Pete in Mountain View.
He's wondering--
a really good question--
if people find bugs,
what do they do?
Where do they file bugs
in relation to the
components of WebRTC?
PUNYABRATA RAY: So we
do have a website.
The first one being
WebRTC.org.
There's a link to there where
you can actually go and it
will help you.
It's a ways forward.
But if you directly want to
go to the code base, its
WebRTC.googlecode.com.
And you will see an issues
list, and you can
file the bug there.
We should probably put
that up somewhere.
If it's not already up there,
but the best way is
WebRTC.org.
RONGHUA WU: But if this is a
Chrome bug, probably just file
bug in Chrome.
PUNYABRATA RAY: Right.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
For those who haven't seen
it, crbug.com is great.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Really nice short
URL, easy to remember.
And if you do file that in the
Chrome issue tracker, and it
needs to go someplace else,
people do triage those
regularly, so we can put that
where it needs to go.
SAM DUTTON: Cool.
OK.
I think that we're going
to wrap up soon.
A couple of things--
if people are watching this
stream, could they 1 the post
so we get an idea of how many
people are out there?
That would be really helpful for
us so that we can work on
these hangouts, and find out
who's watching, and get an
idea of that.
And also another thing-- if
you could do for us--
is to add Chrome developers
to your circles.
That would be a great
way for us to
communicate events like this.
So we're planning on more
hangouts on various APIs and
web-related subjects.
So yeah, just moving back to the
last stuff we've got here.
I think I'll just check
what else we've got.
Eric, and Ray and Ronghua ,
have you got anything else
you'd particularly like to add
before we wrap up today?
PUNYABRATA RAY: No.
Again, if you have any issues or
bugs that you want to file,
please definitely go to either
Chrome bugs or WebRTC.org We'd
love to love to hear from you.
And let us know how--
from a developer perspective--
what you guys think about it.
ERIC BIDELMAN: And what Sam just
mentioned, the great way
to get in contact with us, too,
is through our page, if
you want to sort of open a
channel and communicate back
and forth about some
of this stuff.
Sam, I wonder if it's--
for people that missed the demo
at the beginning of the
WebRTC video--
if it's worth playing again
as we start to wrap up.
SAM DUTTON: That
would be great.
That's a really good idea.
ERIC BIDELMAN: We talked a lot
about WebRTC, and it's
actually good to see
it in practice.
SAM DUTTON: That would be really
nice to see that, just
to finish up on what looks
to me like Willy Wonka's
Chocolate Factory.
ERIC BIDELMAN: That was a
hard day at work, man.
I don't know what you're
talking about.
SAM DUTTON: Jeez, that looks
scary coming down the tube.
[INAUDIBLE]
MALE SPEAKER: Hey, Eric.
What's up?
ERIC BIDELMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
MALE SPEAKER: Hey.
This WebRTC stuff?
It seems pretty cool, right?
Yeah, it is.
ERIC BIDELMAN: I'm kinda
thirsty though, man.
Can you help me out?
MALE SPEAKER: You know?
I think I can.
I'll be right there.
SAM DUTTON: Oh my God.
[LAUGHTER]
[CLAPPING]
SAM DUTTON: Beautiful.
That's really nice.
OK.
Well, thank you so much to Ray
and Ronghua for coming today
and talking about
WebRTC with us.
And please add your comments
to the post or get in touch
with us and file bugs
as you hit them.
And we're really looking
forward to--
it's going to be some great
imaginative stuff, as we've
already seen--
people doing really good
things with WebRTC.
So thanks a lot.
PUNYABRATA RAY: Thank
you, guys.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Thanks,
everyone.
SAM DUTTON: And thanks, Eric.
And thanks to the invisible
man in the page.
He's hard to see.
ERIC BIDELMAN: See you
guys next time.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]